[Musique]
je reviens à vos jean claude carrière
vous avez une production d'une abondance
d'une variété et d'une qualité tout à
fait exceptionnel parce que vous êtes
romancier et historien vous êtes ici
vous êtes même encyclopédistes alors
vous êtes auteur dramatique vous écrivez
pour le théâtre vous adapté aussi bien
pour jean louis barrault surtout pour
pertes et brooke d dépit des gros cons
aussi bien des pièces de shakespeare que
de que de tchekhov et puis surtout vous
êtes un scénariste très connu du cinéma
puisse vous avez travaillé pour peer et
ex luis bunuel louis malle jacques deray
volker schlöndorff wajda forman etc
j'en oublie alors comment fait-on pour
rester soi même avec votre personnalité
quand on travaille quand on écrit
surtout pour des gens qui sont
totalement différents il faut évidemment
trouver un centre à son activité
si on ne veut pas passer pour être
dispersés ce qu'on me reproche sans
arrêt ce centre je crois qui tient en un
mot c'est d'être un compteur
mon métier c'est de choisir des
histoires et de les raconter à mes
semblables à ceux qui vivent en même
temps que moi aujourd'hui
en utilisant les moyens d'aujourd'hui et
chaque fois en choisissant le moyen qui
me semble le plus approprié à l'histoire
que qui m'a paru être intéressante
dans ce cas là c'est la controverse de
valladolid dont j'ai fait le pouvant
choisir un livre et un film de
télévision
oui mais rien n'est alors pour les plus
jeunes je le dis parce que vous êtes
belle de jour et le charme discret de la
bourgeoisie de bunuel entre autres parce
qu'on ait fait d'autres mais c'est vous
la piscine et borsalino de jacques deray
c'est vous le voleur et milou en mai de
louis malle c'est vous le retour de
martin guerre de daniel vigne c'est vous
danton elle est possédée de wajda
c'est vous alors cyrano de bergerac
évidemment c'est un petit peu de vous
parce que je vais évidemment la c mais
si vous l'avez quand même le film de
rappeneau vous avez aidé à son
adaptation
et puis le retour de casanova d'edouard
niermans ce qui va représenter l'un des
trois films qui va représenter la france
à cannes avec alain delon et luchini et
bien c'est encore vous est d'ailleurs
j'ai le plaisir de dire aux
téléspectateurs que vous verrez pour la
première fois un extrait de ce film le
retour casanova à la fin de cette
émission alors ce n'est pas un reproche
que vous faites là non pas du tout je ne
l'accusé pas du tout mais je me dis
alors
je me dit vous savez que vous aimez
raconter des histoires mais pourquoi
n'êtes vous pas devenu vous même le
réalisateur de ces histoires parce que
je crois que je suis plus à ma place là
où je suis tout le monde a envie dans le
cinéma de devenir réalisateur il faut
savoir que quand on devient metteur en
scène de film que ce soit pour la
télévision pour le cinéma on ne peut
plus rien faire d'autre un metteur en
scène est l'homme d'une idée fixe il
doit se lever tous les matins pendant
trois ans de sa vie brisson nous le dira
avec la même idée si la laisse tomber
personne n'est là pour la ramasse et je
crois que je suis d'une curiosité plus
diverses
je m'intéresse à plusieurs histoires
métier au fond c'est de chercher des
histoires de les choisir et de les
transmettre
je m'en tiens à ça j'ai c'est que ces
histoires soient très intéressante pour
ceux qui les écoutent où les limes nous
a quand même été tenté par la mise en
espace que vous postez récente d'un
court métrage effet plusieurs c'est
métrage est en effet oui pour voir un
peu ce que c'est j'ai même été comédien
oui c'est moi que les comédiens très
très passionnant de passer de l'autre
côté de la caméra pour essayer de
résoudre le problème que je passe ma vie
à poser aux autres de temps en temps
c'est ses traits le métier et un tous
les postes de dans un tournage de deux
films tout ce qui concerne l'édification
d'une pièce de théâtre et même
l'écriture le rapport avec son éditeur
avec jean claude simoën dans ces gars là
sont extrêmement précieuse pour un
auteur il doit connaître ces problèmes
là je parle d'un moteur d'aujourd'hui
mais vous pouvez mener en même temps
l'écriture d'une comédie d'un filtrage
en même temps non à la suite l'un de
l'autre c'est à dire je me distrait
quelquefois d'un film difficile par un
roman plus léger mais je ne peux pas
faire deux choses en même temps ce qui
est possible de faire je crois est même
recommandée
c'est décrire la moitié de la journée
est de passer le reste de la journée par
exemple à travers avec des comédiens à
participer aux répétitions d'une pièce à
faire un travail physique ça c'est
indispensable aussi à hama ville où vous
avez quand même disposition une mémoire
et alors je sais pas si c'est plus
documentation ou est faible une
bibliothèque des bibliothèques
disposition absolument pas tellement non
je crois pas je crois que je suis
relativement calme dans mon travail je
suis agent me connaît bien nous avons
beaucoup travaillé ensemble oui j'ai une
bonne bibliothèque
je lis pas mal presque autant que vous
non mais vous
moi quand même phénoménal mémoire
peut-être oui mais surtout une habitude
du travail
thema été donnée il ya trente ans que ça
dure comme est donc rapidité du travail
une certaine rapidité ne peut être une
faculté de me concentrer sur ce que je
fais de m'isoler que je peux travailler
dans dans un bistrot dans un aéroport du
sud de l'inde etc
rien n'obligeait dit aux téléspectateurs
c'est que vous êtes le président en plus
de la femis c'est à dire l'école qui
avait pris la succession de l'idex dire
que l'école pour l'image ils sont bons
sans la russie c'est encore du travail
c'est le cas de bris la présence oui oui
c'est bien travaillé chez vous avec avec
grande efficacité
alors moi je vais quand même je
regardais comme tous ces films toutes
ces pièces des as tu me disais bon vous
avez dit c'est le conteur je me dis
quand même je regarde souvent ce qu'est
ce qui vous anime très souvent les
sujets que vous choisissez c'est quand
même la défense de l'homme sorte de
défense de la liberté oui je m'en suis
rendu compte moi-même je crois cette
insigne de lâche quand on a 25 30 ans où
on aime divertir et uniquement divertir
et d'ailleurs le divertissement est
extrêmement précieux dans dans dans la
vie j'ai commencé avec tati et pierre et
ex et puis peu à peu on se rend compte
surtout quand on fait de la télévision
de sa responsabilité c'est à dire
l'histoire que que nous racontons va
être vu par des millions de gens même si
ce n'est pas réussi on n'a pas le droit
de le raconter n'importe quoi dans le
monde où nous vivons et dans le
connaissons les menaces et les faits les
dangers c'est vrai peut-être ce que vous
dites et on en vient la controverse
valladolid vous l'avez dédié à luis
bunuel avec qui vous avez fait plusieurs
films
donc voilà je travaillais 19 ans et plus
parce qu'il était à la fois espagnols et
mexicains
il avait ni en espagne en 1900 et du
quai par des jésuites espagnol dans
l'idée que la découverte de l'amérique
par les espagnols avaient été une très
bonne chose pour l'espagne bien entendu
mais aussi pour les indiens on l'avait
emporté la vraie religion est la vraie
civilisation par la suite
à 45 ans il est allé s'établir au
mexique et il est devenu mexicain il a
réappris et ils en parlaient très
souvent à découvrir un peuple dont il
parle est quelquefois en mettant le mot
entre guillemets comme des entrepôts pic
tech dont on les répare les
dans son enfance donc cette controverse
de valladolid qui est un événement de
l'histoire espagnole qui a réellement eu
lieu
nous en parlions souvent et il était
passionnant pour moi de voir l'évolution
de bunuel jeunes écoliers catholiques
jeune homme surréaliste et finalement
réalisateur mexicain
alors comment faut-il consommer est-ce
qu'il faut consommer le livre avant le
film où le film avant le livre le livre
est plus et plus long bien entraver le
vélo c'est le blog certains acadiens
beaucoup de choses que que le film sage
de là c'est la liberté de chacun
en ce qui me concerne je n'ai pas pu
choisir ayant réuni là la documentation
je me suis dit des rames a tiré un livre
indiscutablement et en même temps pour
la première fois de ma vie en écrivant
le livre je mettais de côté ce qui
allait me servir au scénario je me
disais ça oui cet élément-là cette
réplique cet assaut cet échange peut
très bien passer dans les attitudes et
dans la voix des comédiens
alors moi j'ai que j'ai consommé d'abord
s'cusez moi dans le film que j'ai vu est
bon j'ai dit que c'est un film superbe
je pense qu'alors vous allez avoir tous
les sept d'heures à la fin de l'année
vous allez il faut dire il faut dire que
ces gens dit elle verra qui a fait le
film et qui avez vous aviez fait
ensemble boulevard et pécuchet c'est
l'algérie qui vous aviez déjà été
couronnés et là vous allez tout rafler
encore c'est évident et je dis vraiment
il fournir le lit alors après j'ai lu le
livre et c'est vrai que le livre qui est
tout à fait proche du du film simplement
il va un peu plus loin il ya des
dialogues plus nombreux plus le livre
permet aussi quelque chose que ne permet
pas un film c'est de pénétrer dans la
pensée des personnages le une caméra est
toujours à l'extérieur les personnages
l'écriture romanesque celle du récit
permet à certains moments avec toutes
les précautions d'usagé quand il s'agit
d'approcher la mentalité des siècles
passés
mais d'essayer de savoir ce qui se passe
dans dans l'âme et dans le coeur de mon
personnage pense aux téléspectateurs se
disent qu'est ce que c'est que cette
controverse ier du livre est quand même
en parler
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est une
controverse qui a eu lieu à valladolid
capitale de l'espagne 16e siècle madrid
ne le deviendra que 20 ou 30 ans plus
tard entre
home est le thème de la religion est le
thème de la controverse concernés les
habitants du nouveau monde
on avait découvert des des continents
dont on a cru au début qu'il s'agissait
d un dray et dont on se rend compte
qu'il s'agit de continents séparés qui
ont évolué pendant des milliers d'années
on ne sait pas encore très bien
aujourd'hui on sait que c'est environ
trente ou quarante mille ans tout à fait
isolé du reste du monde qui sont les
habitants de ce continent
alors deux théories s'affrontent nous
aurons sans doute locales et elle a
découvert ses 490 au monde le sait et
cela nous aurait 115 150 mètres soixante
ans plus tard ils sont maintenant la
découverte des antilles mais la
découverte du continent de mexico et la
prise même de thé dans ce type lame qui
va devenir mexico c'est beaucoup plus
tard ses tanks 1 121
donc il y a une trentaine d'années qui
ont passé mais tous les problèmes sont
là déjà
alors sur quoi portent la controverse
est ce que la question est la suivante
tous les textes fondateurs du
christianisme disent que le christ est
venu redant et tous les hommes or voici
qu'on découvre des civilisations très
avancés avec des empires très bien
organisés avec des impôts ce qui a épaté
les espagnols signe de civilisation et
qui n'ont jamais entendu parler de la
parole du christ oui c'est vrai il est
en arrivant qu'il retenait alors comment
se fait-il que la parole du christ n'est
jamais été portés sur cette terre il est
inconcevable que dieu est oubliée n'est
pas connu
certains des habitants de la terre il
veut pas se tromper alors l'attitude de
ceux qui disent que les indiens ne sont
pas vraiment des hommes et de dire dieu
n'a pas voulu d'eux dans son royaume il
ne les a pas admis auprès de lui voilà
pourquoi il la parole n'a jamais été
porté là bas la parole de l'évangile à
cela s'oppose à l'intérieur même de
l'église
d'autres voient bien entendu y compris
la voix du pape qui dès le début des 493
prêche la tolérance l'humanité la
justice et pourtant ce pape est un
borgia beau fria c'est à dire un
espagnol donc il faut il ne faut pas
penser que la controverse de valladolid
est un livre polémique au sujet de
l'attitude de l'église pas du tout à
l'intérieur même de l'église les deux
tendances sont représentées
depuis longtemps de la question
fondamentale est ce que c'est parce que
pourquoi parce que tout cela c'est la
faute d'aristote par ce qu'aristote
philosophe dominant au le coût par tout
le moyen âge oui on la donne et qui a
beaucoup influencé la somme théologique
de thomas d'aquin qui domine toute la
pensée théologique du moyen âge et de la
renaissance
aristote a établi que dans l'humanité
que nous connaissons il y à différentes
catégories et il y a en particulier des
peuples entiers et des individus qui
sont né esclave esclaves de nature bien
entendu à reste n'est pas idiot il
apporte des nuances à ce jugement
il dit que la nature peut se tromper qu
on trouve de la noblesse
chez certains esclaves et un sentiment
vulgaire et mesquin chez certaines âmes
nobles dites nobles mais dans l'ensemble
la notion de catégorie est admise est là
où le raisonnement devient presque
pervers c'est de dire que bien entendu
ces esclaves sont destinés à servir les
autres mais que si on leur donne
l'indépendance
si on leur enlève leur condition
d'esclaves ils sont perdus autrement dit
ils ont besoin de m oui mais ça c'est
larry scott mais jésus à autre chose
alors c'est là où où se situe la
controverse nous sommes en plein dedans
sepulveda a fait deux arrêts félicien
alors le méga du pape est joué par jean
carmet l or nous sommes regardés du fil
les voici dos le légat du pape qui vient
qui va présider cette controverse
voici donc comment les gars du pape qui
est cardinal qui est joué par jean
carmet introduit la controverse
mes chers frères
depuis que par la grâce de dieu le
royaume d'espagne a découvert et conquis
il use and de l'ouest que certains
appellent déjà le nouveau monde
nous avons vu s'élever un grand nombre
de questions difficiles que rien dans
l'histoire du monde ne laissait prévoir
une de ces questions qui est de première
importance n'a jamais reçu de réponse
claire et complète
c'est elle qui nous réunit ici ses
terres nouvelles ont des habitants qui
ont été vaincus et soumis au nom du vrai
dieu se parlant depuis une trentaine
d'années des rumeurs se sont répandues
en europe dix ans que les indigènes de
mexico et des îles de la nouvelle
espagne ont été très injustement
maltraités par les conquérants espagnols
[Musique]
ces rumeurs que les ennemis de l'espagne
la hollande l'angleterre la france veut
avoir exagéré sont parvenus à sa
sainteté le pape il sans les montrer
vivement ému
d'autant plus que ces traitements
s'exercerait au nom de notre sainte
religion absolument magnifique et dans
le livre carrière dit dans le livre 10,2
du légat du pape
il a la faiblesse des mets bien parler
et qu'on apprécie et ça c'est formidable
parce qu'effectivement on voit dans
votre jeu que vous aimez bien parler et
qu'on ait vous aimé qu'on vous apprécie
son et d'ailleurs est dans le livre il a
un nom alors que dans le scénario il
n'en avait pas oui j'étais tout à fait
satisfait d'apprendre que j'avais une
identité étant donné que ddd des trois
personnages de la controverse c'est le
seul qui soit dans l'imagination de
l'auteur les d'autres étant exactement
las casas et sepulveda alors je sais pas
la première fois que vous jouez le rôle
d'un ecclésiastique ont joué le curé de
tours de balsa oui j'ai joué quelques
prêtres dans des vaudevilles oui qu'ils
n'avaient aucune prétention artistes et
de jouer pas mal oui mais c'est dans la
hiérarchie de l'église c'est le plus
haut pour moi c'est une promotion très
importante cette année que j'ai
appartenu à l'église ayant était enfant
de choeur oui est passé que tel un coup
influent du rose de l'enfant de choeur à
la pourpre cardinalice tu sais quand
même une source inattendue mais je pense
que jean claude carrière qui est avec
qui on est assez liés parce que ça fait
en plus de ça de 2,10 relation qu'on a
dans la vie ça fait quelques années
qu'on travaille ensemble
il a un plaisir pervers à boire quelques
fois dans des costumes aidant il est
très très possible que tout d'un coup ça
soit défini dans sa tête pour le plaisir
de me voir habillée en cardinal comme le
plaisir lui était venu de me voir d'être
le mari de
elle fut une série d'appareils c'est un
couple absolument contre la tuerie oui
mais il n'empêche qu'il empêche que son
choix est judicieux choix de puisqu'avec
verra qu'ils ont dû vous choisir
ensemble et bien le choix et on a des dd
choix oui ça se passe tellement
curieusement non mais vous alors vous
êtes formidable parce que c'est vrai
qu'on non c'est vrai et on se faisait un
plaisir on sent plaisir ecclésiastique a
mené sept contrôleurs la mono remédier
hervé ces gens là sont entraînés à
parler c'est une époque où la recherche
de la vérité la science n'existant pas
encore tels que la collection
aujourd'hui passe par l'exercice de la
parole dans ce genre de joutes oratoires
et également dans les conciles dans le
synode s'est le plus convaincant non pas
qu'ils l'emportent mais qui possède la
vérité
on suppose même que dieu et de son côté
à ce qu'ils parlent mieux alors voici
l'impression d'ailleurs d'être dans une
émission de télévision mais là avec une
fonction tout ecclésiastiques
voici vous présenter les deux opposants
nous avons réuni ici
avaya dolly dans ce couvent ou frère
gregorio a eu la bonté de nous
accueillir quelques témoins et
participants est tout d'abord le très
illustre frère bartolomé de las casas
qui connaît bien les terres nouvelles et
qui plusieurs fois pris la défense de
ces indigènes
or en face nous avons m sepulveda
lui-même ses oeuvres philosophiques sont
très bien connus
son érudition et la pénétration de son
esprit nous seront précieuses
alors jean pierre marielle donc ces deux
fameux las casas qui communiquent
d'ailleurs sa fougue sa navigation
l'acteur idéal mais seulement pour deux
rôles mais pour celui là
particulièrement il a le même le
physique d'une personne alors qui est
las casas las cases à l'époque de la
controverse à 66 ans il a été très jeune
en amérique il a fait 14 fois la
traversée de l'océan atlantique dans les
conditions d'un confort invraisemblable
nourrir deux fois naufrage il a perdu 9
de ses compagnons dominicain toute sa
bibliothèque qui s'est battue après nuit
la traversée des jeunes c'est un
baroudeur de la fois c'est quelqu'un qui
est allé en qualité de missionnaires et
de colons là bas donc il connaît très
très bien le problème
et dès le début il a considéré les
indiens d'amérique comme ses frères et
comme il le dit très souvent dans ses
oeuvres comme son prochain
il est le défenseur absolue de l'égalité
du de l'autre de d'autrui de celui dont
on perçoit d'abord la différence
de ce point de vue il est certainement
presque prophétique à son époque car
certaines des phrases qu'il prononce et
qu'il a réellement écrite dans ne ment
pas le texte de la controverse mais nous
avons les textes des oeuvres de les
réunir alors j'ai fait toute une toute
une construction et tout un un travail
de recherche certaines des phrases qu'il
prononce l'église mettra longtemps
longtemps à les admettre est allé à les
comprendre alors en face de lui c'est le
philosophe sepulveda qui est joué par
jean louis trintignant
c'est à dire avec froideur avec une
intelligence tranquille et j'irai presse
même excusez moi presque avec une sorte
de diabolisme parfois oui je lui ai
demandé
nous tous et jean daniel verhaeghe aussi
d'être tout à fait sincère dans ce match
car il n'était pas question étant donné
que je suppose qu aujourd'hui nous
sommes tous beaucoup plus du côté de las
casas que du côté de sepulveda qui est
l'aristotélisme il a traduit d'ailleurs
aristote à l'époque un espagnol le la
politique d'aristote
mais cet homme n'est pas du tout un
sacripant ni à salonique un menteur ni
un hypocrite il est parfaitement
convaincue de ce qu'il dit et il le
défend avec une habileté rhétorique
alors ce n'est pas du tout un baroudeur
comme las cases au contraire vous avez
vu les beaucoup plus pâle c'est je
développe beaucoup plus évidemment dans
leurs lignes dans le livre c'est un
homme de cabinet c'est un homme d'études
c'est un homme droit toute sa vie il
n'est jamais allé là bas il ne connaît
pas des indiens
mais il ya une pratique de la
disputation de la dispute verbale que
las casas lui envient alors voici donc
les deux tous les deux c'est dire la
skies et sepulveda en pleine controverse
il n'en ce jeudi pour le moment que la
réunion c'est leur naïveté sans mesure
et nous n'étions nous pas naïfs et nous
en gagnons nous pas chercher les sirènes
et les amazones des hommes avec la tête
dans la poitrine des pygmées se drapant
dans les pays de leurs oreilles éminence
le monde est plein de rêves et de
rumeurs
ce continent nous était inconnu il a
grandi sans doute presque seule et
depuis des milliers d'années
la rencontre a stupéfait tout le monde
parce que rien était semblable
même les animaux même les arbres étaient
espèces différentes
il n'avait ni boeufs moutons pourquoi
dans demande s'ils divergent les êtres à
l'apparence humaine seraient ils les
seuls à être semblable éminence tout
indique que dieu les a désignés à notre
pouvoir
vous devez également savoir qu'ils sont
incapables de comprendre les choses les
plus simples comme la rédemption du
christ ou le pardon de la confession
ils n'ont aucune activité de l'âme
aucune idée de l'art allez dire ça
aucune activité de l'âme en ce moment
même à mexico les franciscains ont
trouvé un collège les padres un collège
où les fils des princes aztèque
reçoivent notre éducation ils ont les
mêmes dispositions les mêmes résultats
que les espagnols n'est ce pas vrai
c'est vrai certains font même des verts
latin vous avez bien dit les fils de
prolo architecture avant tout
détruisions toute leur vie cortes lui
même écrivait le roi d'espagne qu'il
n'avait jamais rien vu d'aussi beau sur
ses terres il visait exactement
rien de comparable en espagne la plus
belle chose du monde
et que dire de cette phrase quelques-uns
d'entre nous se demandait c'est ce que
nous voyons là n'était pas un rêve alors
en vérité le légat du pape
c'est déjà là il a une idée du verdict
est d'ailleurs non seulement une idée
mais tout ça est enfin bien définis avec
la complicité de la couronne alors ce
qui est on va pas tout dire parce que ce
qui est vrai ce qu'on peut dire
simplement c'est qu'à la fin
effectivement le légat du pape
décide que les indiens ont une âme et
donc il faut respecter les indiens
meilleur un coup de théâtre alors je
crois qu'il faut pas le dire parce que
sinon c'est un peu dommage bien coup de
théâtre extraordinaire
je crois vous avez lu le lido me crie
le personnage de sepulveda et et c est
assez terrifiant parce que ils manient
la logique et on a l'impression qu'ils
sont
son seul univers de référence c'est pas
les êtres c'est uniquement la logique du
raisonnement et il va poursuivre son
adversaire et est traqué chacune de ces
failles et chaque fois essayé de
l'enfermer à la terminologie qui paraît
absolument implacable ce jour d'échec il
en arrive même à dire j'ai raison dans
ce que je défends mais en admettant que
je me trompe ce que mon adversaire ne le
reconnaît pas à labé tant la chose
inconcevable qu'aristote se trompent
j'ai aussi raison ça c'était une
dialectique extraordinaire j'ai si j'ai
raison j'ai raison mais si j'ai tort
j'ai aussi raison oui et il le prouve sa
c2 c'est une ces bruits c'est un effet
diabolique comme vous dites et ça
suppose une activité de cabinet
d'ailleurs on a on a jar daniel
verhaeghe a voulu que jean louis
trintignant et la couleur blême des
pages de ces de ces parchemins s'efforce
de transformation physique d'ailleurs
assez étonnant maintenant parce que je
suis à peine maquillée jeun j'ai juste
un un maquillage un peu blême y penser
maintenant que tous les jours le fait
non mais le fait le fait de ce costume
d'être en concédant sept
dans ce col ça donne une espèce de
d'aplatissement du visage de
prolifération des graisses c'est une
chose absolument étonnante on est
surpris des uns et les autres on a eu
une très très grande économie de
maquillage un et ça c'est très étonnant
de voir ce qui s'est passé en nous avec
quelle à quel point on a été transformé
et là vous avez des robes sait si la
pluie kg 8 kg 8 qui donne comment vous
faisiez on faisait d'ailleurs c'était
terrible moi j'avais c'était sous mon
saoul matap c'était un vieil tape
contenant tandis que j'avais les jambes
que des jambes qui enflait avec parce
que c'était éclairer tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps j'avais les
jambes qui enflait du fait de la chaleur
alors j'étais dans un bain de pieds moi
je pouvais pas bouger les autres bouger
j'avais un banquier comme ça je peux
même vous dire que j'avais encore
maintenant je veux plein de choses là en
tout tout tout était sombre sous ma
table vous voulez bien peu qu à vous
excuser moi vous avez un besoin la
miction oui eh bien vous décevoir je
suis fier c'était le cas vous savez que
que quand bourdaloue prêcher ses
serments était tellement long que les
dames aller l'écouter avec un appareil
en parcelles sous laquelle mettait sous
leur et qu'on appelle encore aujourd'hui
en bourdaloue oui c'est vrai mais
ailleurs il m'avait prévenu jean-claude
il m'avait dit tu peux y aller si tu en
as envie on le faisait à l'époque et ça
ne fera en rentrant plus dans le
personnage
mais jean carmet c'est quand même un
régal pour un comédien de lire de dire
des textes comme ça oui c'est un régal
ça a été d'abord un régal énorme d'abord
de dire le texte et puis aussi et
support flagorneurs avec mémé mes
copains mais le déshériter jouer parce
qu'on a toujours été parce qu on avait
chacun notre parti là dedans et on a
toujours un moment on était le
spectateur des autres et quand j'étais
le spectateur de jean louis où le
spectateur de jean pierre
et même de jean-michel les gens
d'ailleurs oui et non mais c'était
jean-michel dupuis qui jouait encore à
jean miché oui j'avais chez dupuis qui
jouent en commun dès lors c'est à dire
un colon l'espagnol qui vient faire ce
qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui du
lobbying
c'est à dire défendre les intérêts
matériels de j'avais un plaisir et extra
on avait je pense d'ailleurs il s'est
passé une chose on n'a jamais quitté le
plateau pour le pendant de travail des
autres la réplique of a toujours été
donné de la place et avec la même
intensité parce que le plaisir de
spectateurs ont lavé avec les autres et
quand on reprenait une prise quelquefois
comme on fait au cinéma on avait
toujours le plaisir d'entendre une façon
de nuance est totalement différente est
alors un acteur comme google faisait
beaucoup travaillé pour le cinéma
est-ce que là il est pas aussi fier d'un
film qui n'est que pour la télévision
bien sûr je suis extrêmement fier
d'avoir tourné le curé tour pour la
télévision d'avoir tourné il ya quelques
années avec jean claude carrière la
double vie de théophraste longuet qui
était une oeuvre littéraire très
importante est d'avoir d'avoir tourné
bouvard et pécuchet l'année dernière et
d'avoir tourné les étonnements d'un
couple moderne avec delphine série là on
tourne ça avec d'abord des metteurs en
scène tout à fait remarquable avec qui
on a pu travailler avant on c'est un
luxe d'ailleurs pour nous de faire de
d'être au départ d'une aventure pareille
parce qu'une avant bouvard et pécuchet
avec jean-claude on en a parlé pendant
sept ou huit ans ensemble bon et pour
avant de réunir les éléments et puis
maintenant s'y trouvaient là pendant
quelques temps jean-claude ont parlé
tout à l'heure de la mémoire de
jean-claude un la mémoire de jean claude
est une mémoire totalement active parce
que il raconte les sujets avant de les
accrocher
je ne savais pas ce que c'était que
valladolid un jour il m'a parlé de
valladolid
et puis on à dire enfant s'est vu dans
l'oeil en disant que ça va faire ça
ferait de bien belles images de mikari
c'est cette histoire d'un contrôle via
de l'ide c'est à l'honneur de l'église
ou au contraire c'est et que comment
vous sortez de ce livre vous dites au
fond l'église c'était
conduite ignominieuse pendant des années
ou au contraire finalement c'est son
mérite d'avoir reconnu ses crimes
je dirais que c'est un peu c'est un peu
les deux c'est à dire que elle et elle
est comme elle est faite des hommes avec
leurs leur propre mentalité du moment et
avec leur aveuglement avec leurs idées
fixes avec leurs intérêts et peut-être
son mérite c'est à certains moments
d'oser dire alors ça lui arrive
peut-être pas assez souvent au goût de
certains
meadows et regarder la vérité en face et
de dire eh bien là on a une conduite qui
est qui qui est critiquable et qu'il
faudrait qu'il faudrait changer on a eu
des exemples plus récent de deux des
types de ce genre voulez parler de la
sphère douvier là je tends sans partir
il faut préciser que cette controverse
de valladolid est la première du genre à
ne jamais jusque là dans l'histoire on
ne s'était posé la question sepulveda
dit à un moment donné ce sera toute à la
gloire de l'espagne d'avoir engagé même
limité ce débat là jusque là dans toute
l'histoire des guerres le travail en ce
moment avec daniel vigne sur
vercingétorix et césar pour essayer d'en
faire un film
mais à l'époque de césar on ne se pose
pas la question l'ennemi captifs et
vaincus et un esclave
on le vend c'est la marchandise même la
plus recherchée dans dans toute
l'antiquité on fait ce qu'on veut avec
lui alors que on commence à se poser la
question de l'autre parce que finalement
c'est la seule question qui est cet
homme
cette femme différent de moi qui sont
ils c'est un effet tout à la gloire de
ceux qui ont tout à l'honneur de ceux
qui ont engagé le débat pour la première
fois un débat qui vous le savez très
bien est loin d'être être complétée
aujourd'hui les conséquences de cette
controverse de valladolid ont été très
très importante pour le monde
d'ailleurs le
les gars du peuple dit sondés sont des
choses qui nous régissent maintenant et
ça a été la mort ce d'une forme de
libéralités quand même très très
importante
je me disais pourquoi on n'a pas fait on
a fait un fils de télévision souhaitait
fait un film de cinéma
vous auriez montrer les horreurs quand
j'ai marié le racontent des horreurs
épouvantable des soldats des colons qui
sont là bas qui tue qui violent qui
s'est épouvante et et je me dis est ce
que cette voix de marielle qui raconte
ses horreurs c'est pas plus fort que si
on ne me racontait envoyait les types à
séoul a vu cet effort parce que si on le
voyait on serait que c'est faux on s'il
aime aussi les mains jusqu'à maintenant
on ne tue pas vraiment ça peut venir un
jour mais enfin en tout cas là quand il
le raconte ça a plus de force de vérité
par l'évocation si l'acteur est comme
jean pierre marielle excellent très
animé à vos moments et très habité au
moment où il le dit ça nous donne à voir
parce que nous ajoutons à ce qu'il dit
des images que la télévision ou la
presse nous donne en pâture tous les
jours
les images de tel ou tel massacre que
nous voyons en nous savons très bien que
les massacres ne sont pas terminées
autour de loudon ça permet cette espèce
de contrainte d'être dans dans un lieu
enfermé nous permet qu'en le voyant le
film quand nous lisons le livre bien
entendu de dinde il ya ajouté des
propres imaginez vous êtes d'accord jean
claude brisseau là dessus ou et non la
seule chose que je dirais c'est que le
fait de montrer à l'heure actuelle dans
le cadre comme ça organiserait
vraisemblablement la jouissance du
spectateur sur le salissement ce qui est
devenu la logique du cinéma américain
j'étais il ya trois semaines à los
angeles et j'ai rencontré le producteur
de terminator 2 et ainsi qu'un autre
producteur il était en train de me dire
que la logique et d'etel avec ce type de
film puisqu'il faut qu'il ait pas
dépense des milliards de centimes avant
même qu'un film soit commencée pour
avoir le comédien la star le réalisateur
important qu'ils sont obligés d'aller
toujours plus loin pour viser et presque
toujours plus bas en ce qui concerne le
ca spectateurs dont on est sûr qu'il au
cinéma qui vont au cinéma
les jeunes et ils espèrent un changement
dans les goûts du public
mais tel qu'ils s'organisent ça
m'étonnerait et la violence devient pour
eux quasiment nécessaire
dans la mesure où ils ont besoin d'avoir
des gens en salle oui donc aux états
unis a filmé comme ça que j'avais pu
faire tourner tout simplement de
remontrer alors les noms mais même pour
le snav
vous savez là j'étais je suis très
content de constater vous faites de la
publicité pour une et un téléfilm parce
que je me rappelle qu'il ya trois ans ou
quatre ans mon film précédent noce
blanche
je voulais le faire un moment pour
antenne 2 et on m'a dit c'est impossible
parce que la logique de la privatisation
est telle qu'on peut plus faire de
téléfilms individuel en ce sens pour
voir exactement ce qui m'a été dit à
l'époque on nous a dit si jamais on fait
un téléfilm c'est pour que le spectateur
le voit or s'il est vraiment intéressant
on est obligé de le programmer une
certaine date et la chaîne concurrente
va nous mettre en même temps un film de
cinéma ou un autre téléfilm et du même
coup on pourra pas rivaliser on va faire
le strict 2 le téléfilm pour rien alors
on ne produit plus que des grandes
séries qui ont leur pub tout fait et je
trouve si vous voulez je trouve que
cette logique là est extrêmement
dommageables pour l'ensemble de la
création est entre autres pour la
télévision et mais ça c'est la
concurrence infernal des désaccords mais
là c'est très bien le samedi parce qu'il
n'y a pas de pas de film le samedi donc
que vous êtes bien placés sur fr3 vers
si les gens ne voient de vous re préfère
les autres émissions
bah tant pis pour eux ça évidemment on
peut pas les obliger à regarder bon je
rappelle que c'est le samedi 2 mai voilà
et on termine là sur le
sur le questionnaire alors vous allez
répondre que derrière messi françoise
verny vous voulez répondre aussi vous
soyez jeudi répond alors votre mot
préféré y en a beaucoup mais ce soir
j'ai bazille là bas là bas l'abba dieu
le mot vous détestez aménagements
racisme le vôtre drogue favori l'hôtel
drouot votre drogue favoritisme
cigarettes la cigarette le son le bruit
que vous aimez va plus la mer le son le
bruit que vous détestez les mobylettes
dans les rues alors la fraîche chez le
dentiste votre juron gros mot blasphème
favori pour ce soir jour en espagnol
mais cavendish
ça veut dire je chie sur dieu tu te dis
c'était un beauf à mme pour illustrer un
nouveau billet de banque
laurel et hardy sans l'ombre d'un doute
je pensais pas de droit puis pourquoi
pas non il a tous les droits
alors qui jeanne d'arc et alors ces gaz
bourg c'est pour ça qu'il a fait de
brûler ce le nayais évidence qu'on
mettait jana alors le métier que vous
n'auriez pas aimé faire kamikaze est
couturière la plante l'arbre où l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
en arbre du voyageur
aucun arbre et aucun animal vous
détestez les bons et si dieu existe
aimeriez vous après votre mort
l'entendre vous dire lucifer nous attend
pour déjeuner jean carmet jean pierre
coffe seront là
[Musique]